[Music]
when I think of my wife it seems like
movies don't get made these days unless
they start with narration movie thinks
it can sneak a Tyler Perry credit by me
hoping I won't notice and wrongfully
hoping I forgiven him for why did I get
married to the morning of what the
morning of what yeah yeah we know it
means this is the morning of her
disappearance but will her disappearance
tell us that okay damn it if half this
movie is gonna be Ben Affleck staring
off into the distance somewhere then I
will be gone girl I mean I won't be
watching this movie anymore get your
present Oh Master Mind was clue too
subtle for this movie about mysteries
and psychological warfare that's it
isn't clue missing from this stack of
games oh wait I forgot
Nick's character is totally clueless in
his movie that crazy brilliant ass
Fincher made me think my way out of a
sin father sitting regardless I I have I
came fast and furious please don't name
the franchise that shall not be named
I'm so crazy stupid happy diary reading
I am narration they already relieved me
of my artisanal meat platter finally
someone tells me how to pronounce that
word me cutesy 1930s quick talking
patter in lieu of speaking like normal
modern humans cliche tone it down Nick
and Nora I rock hipster so self-aware it
makes everything a joke Nick really
knows the way to a woman's heart
stereotyping tuxedo guy was allowed into
what seems to be a relatively classy
party since he's become an amusing part
of Nick and Amy's conversation I can
only assume he was invited by the
screenwriter knock hipster so sophomore
I'm executing a joke the only way this
scene is even remotely believable is if
we find out this is actually some 500
days of summer fantasy sequence that
he's playing in his head to psych
himself up to go talk to this girl he
gets your chin villainous maybe that's
why Batman seemed like the bad guy
during that bold movie I watched that
one time you have to see this apparently
Nick knows New York so well he knows an
alley where a bakery creates a virtual
sugar storm and 11 excuse to kiss this
woman he just met also Amy follows a man
she just met down an alley without any
question after he says you have to see
this
it's amazing everyone is so surprised
when she goes missing she kissing missed
opportunity for a sugar pun but Who am I
kidding I would have send them for that
too dad is she asking him this like a
caveman
oh wait mcdonnen is his name got it even
though Nick lands on the get married
block he lets Margot spin and doesn't
take the honeymoon spin the rules
dictate
because he doesn't know how to play the
game of life wait maybe that's an
extremely subtle metaphor god damn it -
once
there's no good gift for what I know go
home her brains out slap with your penis
there's some wood for you bitch Margot
says almost exactly what I am thinking
which is definitely a sin neighbor wall
called NIC at the bar to tell him that
his cat escaped but didn't go get the
cat to keep it safe
also the cat stayed in the front yard
from the time of the phone call until
nick arrived home suggest bedroom their
cat's room on the end just a minute ago
we saw that Nick decided to put the cat
his bedroom so if the cat has its own
room why not their detective has some
sort of endearing way of marking crucial
areas of a house with little sticky
notes instead of I don't know taking
pictures detective boney only marks the
blood spatter over the stove even though
there's clearly visible blood spatter on
the bottom cabinets too unless Amy
attended the lesser-known
rattle feed college at Harvard they
definitely spelled Ratcliffe wrong on
her diploma also I'm pretty sure the
person who signed as the president of
Harvard is named something McKee and not
Neal are rotten Stein it was actually
the president of Harvard in 1992 overall
I'm seriously doubting the legitimacy of
Amy's Harvard diploma curious whether
it's difficult for you to see amazing
Amy heading down the aisle and this big
party celebrating this fictional wedding
because it's my understanding you are
not married these journalists and
bloggers decide to take turns asking a
section of the same question like
they're playing an improv game also
botnik his very first pair says Nick an
adult man didn't own scissors until at
most two years ago I don't care how much
of a slob you are everyone needs to cut
with scissors challenge me she surprised
me and have a world-class vagina who
says this to a woman he loves in front
of a whole bunch of reporters except me
to Serena Williams just before a whole
bunch of French police come out to
tackle me Oh son I got a law-and-order
up so that by the way if you don't know
Nick is painfully unaware of his own
actions during this investigation this
movie will make you painfully aware of
his unawareness dad Nick's dad just
happens to be here at the police station
right now which is convenient for the
plot since it makes him remember to go
to his dad's house for the next clue
you're Nick Dunne we've been trying to
get ahold of you all afternoon
so could you not call his sister I don't
understand did they find a secret room
in this bookstore for Amy timpz
coincidentally for Amy tips is the name
of a DVD I own that my wife doesn't know
about also isn't the for superfluous Amy
tips or two six nine eight four seven
seven is enough numbers he attempted
suicide after
broke up with him sophomore year and
thus begins the Miss casting of Neil
Patrick Harris who was way too
well-known for How I Met Your Mother and
just in general being Neil Patrick
Harris when this movie came out sorry
it's just the way it is you know for a
fact someone's going to arrange the
letters on this thing to say help find
Amy's one day so this is pointless to be
trained and paraded husbands who treat
their lives like the Highway Patrol
I feel entitled to a scene from Nick and
Amy's newlywed years where they are
discussing how they are so much better
than normal married couples I think I'm
gonna be laid off or in a recession if
it happens we'll deal with it I'll
probably be next
even though Nick and Amy are both highly
educated and Amy comes from a pretty
influential family they both get laid
off somehow Nick thinks he can just park
that Volvo anywhere you see that guy
like vas is beautiful I tend to get a
lot of Dewar's Frank's so we're just
gonna brush past desi Collings the guy
who amy's parents claimed tried to kill
himself after Amy broke up with him
there's no reason to question him right
apparently Mario records baseball games
on her DVR man still hasn't watched the
game from June 30th which is a week old
at this point also she records the local
news even before Amy's disappearance and
has a couple of them recorded on July
2nd and July 4 this is some DVR nonsense
no one should put up with but I know
Nick is an idiot did you leave the pair
of red pains in my office maybe isn't
putting pennies in someone's office the
type of thing you definitely remember
like are you putting pennies in so many
places that you forgot about the time
you left a parent in office and isn't
that expensive to check my red panty in
the statement sounds like sarcasm but
I'd be more surprised if she didn't have
a red panty inventory Sean on a gun felt
bad though she seemed really desperate
said it needed to be small so she could
keep it close Amy is either extremely
lucky that this guy would say something
that would fit her narrative so
perfectly or she paid him to say this
also Amy's in Missouri might not buy a
gun legally pretending to be a
responsible citizen makes for a much
neater paper trail know that I'm
ultimately confused giving this scene is
sin but it appears the only reason Andy
was somehow allowed to sleep over at
Nick's sister's house is so we could see
her naked again and because he's the
biggest idiot who ever idiot a during
investigation like this I thought
writers hated clichs
where'd you get that idea have you seen
in the movies they're making these days
cable news is all over your shit Margo
has the fastest DVR on the planet I'm
going so easy on James forgot he's a
police officer who needs hard evidence
to arrest someone and not 30 minutes of
watching HLN
$17,000 in credit card for Amy's plan to
work nick has to absolutely never look
at credit card statements and never get
a call about extravagant charges even
though he and Amy were nearly flat broke
the statement tells us these charges are
60 days past due it's unreal he didn't
get a call about it even to discuss
possible for all she's pregnant did they
use the urine sample that Amy fished out
of the toilet that came from the woman
who was much further along than six
weeks which would show up in the test
results or the blood sample they
obtained from the crime scene that would
prove she actually isn't pregnant movie
expects me to believe Amy was able to
get all this stuff into her
sister-in-law's woodshed without anyone
noticing or getting it delivered to her
house without anyone noticing also if
someone delivered all this stuff there
would be a record of which carrier
delivered it and the cops would find and
question him or her also somehow Margot
shed was never searched during the
investigation or eaten walked into by
Margot herself also it's crazy the
timing of all this for whatever reason
Nick decided not to allow the detectives
to follow these anniversary clues which
would have led them to the shed of all
the stuff she bought to incriminate him
stuff he only found out about when the
detectives brought up the money troubles
and the credit card purchases to fake a
convincing murder you have to have
discipline in any crime documentary I've
ever seen the investigators seem to have
a habit of meticulously tracking the
victims moves and whereabouts leading up
to the time they go missing which
sometimes includes what they purchase
and what they want that being said no
one noticed the fact that Amy had been
buying murder related books and watching
murder documentaries on TV you need to
bleed a lot a lot a lot so much blood
that you would probably pass out and be
unable to stop the bleeding but let's
just say you succeed in losing that much
blood without killing yourself you will
definitely be too weak to finish staging
your crime scene burn it just the right
amount what is the right amount you
don't think anyone will wonder why the
incriminating diary isn't completely
burned you could have left this anywhere
in the house where Nick wouldn't find it
and accomplish the same thing instead
you raise more questions and went to the
beach I thought about our marriage I
came back and decided I wanted a divorce
by the time you got home she was gone
Nick leaves out the part when he goes to
the bar depending on how long he was at
the bar this could be a key part of his
alibi this trip to the bar might make
his timeline too short for him to have
enough time to murder Amy store her body
at a place that can't be found clean up
the mess and go to the bar all before
going back home calling the police
but I know she's not in makeup or
anything but if her face is plastered
all over the news there'd be at least
one asshole who would call and say they
think they saw her she's not in any
discernible disguise not wearing a wig
and still looks like Rosamund Pike for
whatever reason we needed to see Amy
scratching her leg
during a midday googling it stinks that
the find amazing Amy website has the
wrong hotline number on it from what I
can recall the number is actually 855
for Amy tips and before he kissed me he
leaned in and did Tess okay so this
maybe is a fake story that Amy decides
to tell the neighbor but the way it's
presented feels like the absolute truth
this is her actually learning about
Nick's mistress but why would Nick rub
her lips the same way when there's no
sugar to wipe off terrible what you mean
he didn't call first before he came out
here no no she is telling the perfect
story Tyler Perry's swooping in and
saying what I've been sending this whole
time is not what I need right now this
is the prequel to Batman V Superman
Batman V Wallace Keith's be sure to buy
Batman V Wallace Keef the penultimate
edition in stores soon I mean Amy at
this party guy carries around a picture
of the woman who ruined his life in his
wallet because he's a glutton for
punishment I see amy has finally decided
to cover up her appearance slightly but
come on by now she's been seen by so
many people right she just now started
doing this even though Greta has been
following the Amy story it doesn't
strike her that Nancy looks shockingly
similar to Amy it is absolutely insane
that Nick is left alone in this airport
with every TV playing Amy coverage kind
of weird TV show is this that ends at
8:50 Central Time
I'd like to report some strange activity
as soon as a call is placed police can
track where it originated so the fact
that no one thought to investigate the
origins of this call continues to prove
that Amy is the luckiest person ever
staged murder the treasure hunt is
critical she's taking us on a tour of my
infidelities Amy put clues in all the
places where he banged Andi but somehow
this dumb ass realized that's exactly
what the point was even though they're
all common places this also led him to
believe he shouldn't share these clues
with the detectives and it's what also
led to all this suddenly incriminating
evidence being left behind in all three
places stuff that would implicate a me
more than Nick in real investigation
this plan leads way too many things up
in the air to chance and even though I
believe Amy knows Nick enough to play
him like a fiddle I can't believe she
knows every last detail of how he'd act
during a missing wife investigation we
find a I've got to X Secret Service guys
that are really good I'll put them on it
well they aren't that good because they
don't find her nor are they able to
retrace her steps proving she staged
this whole thing Amy who meticulously
planned how to incriminate her husband
for murder carries around large wallets
of cash that easily fall out of her
jacket when she gets too excited oh you
said you were broke how did you know
that was money this shot here just shows
a bag with no money coming out of it and
it certainly doesn't look like the bag
is filled with money in any way
but it's apparently enough visual
evidence to get these thieves interested
in robbing her later why would you do
this huh
even though amy is suspicious and
anxious right now she still opens the
door for the drug addict girl from next
door say her name's Nancy you don't even
answer to it at the time you're hiding I
don't know why and I don't really care
can you not see who she looks like I
know you don't this is the number one
reason why Amy should never be able to
go out in public even without makeup
also why did she call this meeting with
desi at a freaking casino the news is on
and is audible in this casino sis Nancy
Grace surrogate lady always on TV or she
just conveniently on TV whenever any of
the characters in this film turn one off
even though there are security cameras
everywhere amy was unable to see that
desi was about to walk into the house
Nick's taking the back way to his
sister's house which reminds me
didn't Amy call about the woodshed like
a couple days ago well peek into that I
wonder Margo done this is a search
warrant for your property I usually more
tip line calls but a neighbor was
concerned about a strange man around
your woodshed and I continued ignoring
that gone for a couple of days until it
would be convenient for the story to
check into it now this was put here by
me which would be easy to prove if they
did any actual police work surrounding
that stuff instead of just assuming he
put it there and arresting it in her own
words this man may kill me that's kind
of convenient dammit he beat me to it
makes it two by four right big as a club
we found this day one the fireplace in
your home office just tested it fire
doesn't erase blood Nick oh come on you
found this day one and you didn't bother
to check in until just now you did she
cut her own hair like that I don't take
desi for her hairstylist so that only
leaves one option but based on the way
she cut her own hair the first time that
one option doesn't seem to be believable
either Amy stages a post rape scene for
the security cameras knowing the
authorities will view them after desi is
killed yet doesn't worry about the
footage those same cameras captured of
her willingly entering the house weeks
before Annie likes her face with her
bloodied hand and her face remains clean
the wounds are consistent with right the
doc doesn't continue and say also there
is no sign that she was pregnant and
miscarried because US doctors are able
to detect these things can't blame
yourself are all of the federal agents
cops and doctors in this room complete
morons she meticulously her words
staged the crime scene to look like
someone sloppily set up a murder scene
to look like a kidnapping and up until
now all these guys thought Nick killed
her with blunt force trauma because the
amount of blood and the murder
and they found yet no one is wondering
why she doesn't have any wounds that
even remotely come close to something
that would produce the amount of blood
Amy we found her diary it contains many
concerning allegations of mental and
physical abuse Wow now Amy is actively
avoiding parts of the narrative she
orchestrated that give NIC clear motives
to murder her and all these professional
investigators are still buying it and I
think like detective boney is being
ridiculous no more cameras everywhere
please find this the statement could be
potentially incriminating if any of
these federal agents knew how to do
their jobs I shouldn't ask you a whole
of the box cutter the other tide of all
time okay just be happy your wife is
home and safe I know James is an awful
detective but his superior boney is not
and this movie is going to gloss over
all the bull to allow me to be free I'm
sorry I feel myself fading well if she's
fading let's wheel her out of this room
and never be questioned to get that task
for Oh Ben Affleck really like showing
that ass doesn't he wait a minute
did they not wash off all this blood at
the hospital don't they do their tests
and then you know clean somebody up and
let them rest in what's more this blood
comes off like it's still wet apparently
Doogie Howser's blood is resistant to
the environment as simply looking for a
new host when it comes out of his body
sweetie did they both take a three-hour
long shower because it was midday when
they got in the shower and now it looks
like dusk In Touch magazine definitely
covers Nick and Amy Dunn's marriage but
is completely devoid of whatever gossip
there is about Ben Affleck and Jennifer
Garner
are you two animals about people I've
ever known since the guy who created
Madea she can't do anything we had a
national spotlight on us we stained the
rug conveniently this becomes a federal
case just because Bonnie made the wrong
arrest even though everyone in the world
thought Nick killed his wife but even
more conveniently even though does he
was mentioned during the investigation
nobody bothered to check his house or
the lake house during the entire scour
the countryside search which would
approved Amy's story total Bush had
noticed a disposal I have that you threw
it out the notice yes okay this is just
too much deviousness to think about so
many steps ahead Amy apparently threw
out the notice so that Nick would think
his sperm sample was disposed of but at
the time she was not thinking about her
pretend murder yet so what was the point
of making him believe the sample was
destroyed unless she somehow knew her
plan wasn't going to work and she'd need
it to keep the marriage going afterwards
you want to stay with her I guess if he
pulled a million dudes and confronted
them with a situation that Amy put her
husband through you've got at least one
guy probably more who'd stay in the sham
marriage just because there was a kid
involved but god damn it I'm not one of
those dudes there's no
way you could stay with a person like
this what I thought we were in the trust
tree within the nest are we not
you're daring me to be someone I don't
want to be so not like a regular mom I'm
a cool mom
[Music]
I didn't kill my wife I don't care if
you want to see me again come down and
visit me in Florida I always believed it
was the things you don't choose that
makes you who you are you City your
neighborhood
[Music]
I'll ask if you were assisted in any way
you answer yes I'll say how you say I
was given the questions and the answers
advance last was this done routinely you
answered yes can I get you anything to
drink or eat before we get started I
have some Tigers all I've had today is
like six gummi bears and some scotch